hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another world's quietest
let's play
although the elegance of with which I
play these games will be countermanded
by the fact that we are going to be
playing getting over it by the eminent
douchebag known as Bennett Farley now as
we peruse the world of mr. cauldron man
keep in mind I will not scream I will
not rant
I will not rave I will not allow myself
to become the debased [ __ ] that you
all know markiplier to be I will not be
stopped in my quest shut up mr. faught
II leave me to my own devices as I climb
up this mountain of [ __ ] that you
have created you know what you've done
to deserve all the hate that you receive
and yet you stand like a Titan among the
mountain and you stare down I am
entirely happy with my predicament
because I am a paragon of virtue and I
know exactly what it takes to be the one
who succeeds when all others fail and
you will see you will see the inside of
your entrails when I drag them out of
your abdomen and show them to you mr.
cauldron man if you even have legs I'll
be certain to rip them off and replace
your arms with those legs for all the
good your arms are doing you right now
excellent this is a representation of my
sins and you will be purged in the fires
of absolute you will be purged in the
fires of absolution along with all of
your ilk I will burn the heretics that
you are harboring inside of your soul I
will never allow you to survive I will
never I will just breathe everything is
calm peaceful rainbows sunshine and
butterflies
[Music]
why am a deflating balloon of anger I am
a hot air balloon of sass and you will
not prevent me from achieve success you
see what happens when you obey me
success reigns bound upon everybody the
long weary road of success is paved with
failures and I will not be the tea's
ready
I've seen your browser history and I am
NOT impressed I don't know how that
happened
I could I know an impossibility when I
see it and impossible is written all
over the face of this game spilling over
it
I passed a kidney stone please listen to
me once more you sack of OB I'm a calm
peaceful man with calm peaceful
intentions who is going to get through
this with a strength of mine and
strength of soul you don't know I see
what you're doing and I will not allow
it
and we'll take this patiently and I will
take this graciously because I am a
gracious patient man I'm the gracious
patient is Tran ever known to the face
of the ages hat help hat you've betrayed
me just like everyone else you will burn
the fires of my own hell I will choose
your plane to last eternity hat do not
betray me get out of here
you all know everything that is I have
come to deeper convergence then you will
try to rest roomer so
right just as I planned
excellent I have reached the mountain
the zenith the aperture the epicenter
everything has led to this moment and I
will not be dissuaded now by my phone
not by this mountain not by the things
that are trying to stop me nothing get
in my way
not this final Zenith this final moment
this one unquestioning obstacle will
stop being douche and will obey it will
obey every undulating face
[Music]
[Music]
alas
I leave you now to go slumber amongst
the ancient thank you again known as
always I will see you in the next video